the West African Regional block ecowas
has given niger's coup leaders one week
to reinstate the president the block
says if they fail to do so the reaction
is an option land and air borders have
been closed Financial transactions are
blocked
let's bring in Ahmed Reese who's at that
ecowas meeting in Abuja and we
understand the proposal is coming
together by Chad to try and resolve the
crisis what can you tell us about this
happened
well the president of Chad Muhammad
Idris Debbie was here earlier earlier
than most of the president that
participated in the meeting that ended
here today we were told that he was here
for bilateral meeting with an Nigerian
president but his presence there at this
critical time is more than a coincidence
now we're hearing that he is taking a
proposal to the military rulers in Niger
to probably mediate in the crisis
although no mention of Muhammad Derby's
participation in The Echoes uh
proceedings we know Chad is an observer
with the economic community of West
Africa State being a Central African
state but again uh his we also heard in
some of the resolutions that ecowas is
sending a delegation to child now
considering the fact that ecowas
delegation has been spun before by the
military authorities in Nigeria the
presence of Idris Mohammed Debi is an
indication that he is trying to
negotiate a peace full settlement to
this particular crisis and that's what's
been happening today in this wedding and
there is talk about possible military
intervention by ecowas how serious is
that
well it's it's serious there's been a
lot of talk a lot of uh separately by
the regional block uh what is not clear
right now is uh we understand that the
force is going in after one week uh we
are not clear who is going to put the
bill in case of military intervention
hopefully people are waiting to see
whether or not the threats of the threat
of force is enough to deter the military
authorities and force them to reverse
their actions but what we know right now
is that a military force is going into
Nigeria in one week if the authorities
have failed to adhere to the demands of
The Echoes already military Chiefs in
the region member states of ecos
military Chiefs have been ordered to
start making preparations towards that
direction what is not clear at the
moment is who is going to foot the bill
the United Nations is was here at the
meeting members of the European Union
also attended the meeting including the
United States of course diplomats from
these countries attended the meeting and
it's expected that with their support to
president Muhammad basil probably some
of them will help Finance any possible
military intervention in that country
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much Japanese